we have lovely show today yeah excited
about it and I see we're twinning a
little bit we've both not shaved yeah
um and I'm stunned by the face I see in
the morning when I look in the mirror
because I'm used to shaving I shave a
lot I like this look on you it looks
good but it's a total uh you know gold
prospector time it's a it's a ghostly
white uh beard that's freaking me out
yeah so is this the first time you've
had a beer in a while since it's gone
yeah yeah it's gone it's funny it used
to be uh sort of coppery it was redder
than my hair
um sort of well you know kind of like
Prince Harry's beard I'm just saying
that because he's a name that everyone's
talking about and I think I'm a lot like
Prince Harry how so well hounded by the
paps nope I'm forced to leave my native
country to marry the woman I loved
native country yeah which one is it
let's not get into it let's not asking I
don't know what even answer the very
basic question of which country why
can't people just accept that I am so
much like Prince Harry oh because
you're not you're not you're not at all
like him yeah I don't know I was when I
got married people said
sorry ladies but eligible bachelor Conan
O'Brien is off the market
you know you made jokes but probably
people said that they didn't I went
looking
trying to be nice
looking I hired six publicists to scour
through micro microfilm internet
everything no no people have script and
asked them to say that and they said and
they wouldn't do it yeah you know a lot
of women everywhere Rejoice that El
crepo is off the market
headline in the New York Times
um accrual paper uh no I had it it was
very coppery
red and now I'm I'll get up in the
morning and I'll forget that I have you
know I've just let it go yeah and uh I
um I look like my own ghost from the
future I think you look distinguished
well thank you I think you look real
yours looks good oh thank you does it
keep you warm
does it even do does it do anything you
know what it is I remember uh my son
when he was really young asked me
because this is back when I had
originally had my beard for a little
while uh during our touring period
during all that craziness in 2010 and um
he was worried because he thought you
know someday if he'd be able to grow a
beard and he thought that it hurt he
said does it hurt when the hair pushes
up through the skin and I said like you
wouldn't believe oh no you lied yeah I
told him that it's very very it's
unending agony get food stuck in it
I don't think so okay not at this length
but no there is a point no if we really
let it go and I don't know that I'm
really gonna let it go it's easy top it
yeah you know what Letterman Letterman
did that crazy uh escaped convict who's
been living in the woods for six years
beard and um you know the
Rumpelstiltskin beard where he fell
asleep for 15 years and so anyone else
no it's like he grabbed that piece of
pie no what none of us can do that are
you bitter about it very bitter oh I
don't know I would do long mutton chops
long gray mutton chops you know like
whisker Wings yeah like uh like an old
General in the Civil War but down so low
that you could like wrap them under your
armpits and flip them back wait so it's
going why not basically sideburns that
go down and then I braid them with my
armpit hair yes so it all attaches and
then I can it's like a sling for my
iPhone yes and you could like
theoretically move your head to the left
and your right arm will come up yeah
like a puppeting yourself yeah I could
be my own Puppeteer I could be both
puppet and Puppeteer that's what you've
always wanted that's the dream that is
the dream no uh I think uh this will go
uh it'll go go soon but what I will say
is I've sometimes thought of growing
crazy sideburns yeah you should I'm just
real crazy sideburns why not because it
would go with your kind of rockabilly
aspirations yeah do you think you can
do you think you can pull it off what do
you mean pull it off say say be honest I
don't know do you have the do you have
that persona for rockabilly like no for
like sideburns well listen you've seen
me perform rockabilly I know and but you
don't perform all the time I know like
you have you're touring you're not
touring but I could what I'm saying is
if I got the hair combed up and I got
the the flip collar going and I had
crazy sideburns yeah you want to be cool
guy with sideburns here's the problem
when you hit a certain age and you're
still out there playing electric guitar
um uh I remember it was I was playing
once with my band and one of my writers
I don't know if it was Sweeney or Matt
someone said
um that was fantastic it's like a Viagra
commercial and I immediately thought of
the guy who's in his like 60s and there
was one where a guy's playing he's
rocking it out in his band and his wife
who's got long gray hair and his like 60
is with him with a tambourine the minute
I heard that I I burned my guitar but
got a huge boner oh massive
because I didn't realize you're supposed
to just take one I put seven of them in
a smoothie
yeah and I rented myself out as a coat
hook
zero room
but I
I what people coming and hanging things
on your dick well I like that is your
Parry pants I like that anyone if I ever
did myself out to a store Club coat room
because I had a never-ending boner from
meeting seven viagras that they would
accept that because they it's somehow
better than a normal coat hook and not
only that it's one of those coat hooks
that if you pull down it opens a secret
passage yeah to the back of the room but
I scream as you pull it down how many
trees can you hold with your dick are
you kidding me guess what four wet
raincoats and a parka
ladies
just so you know I've tested it these
are wet raincoats not dry dry doesn't
count I know there are some comedians
out there saying oh give me a dry
raincoat four wet raincoats these are
the really good like British raincoats
and uh parka that's Laden with snow and
has two five pound weights in the Mitten
pockets that's what this old
can do
foreign